we unkindled are worthless don't even
die right
gives me conniptions before we get into
Ferren cape i want to talk about the
unconvince what we are Miyazaki was
asked the question what is the
difference between undead and done
kindled at a Taiwanese press event and a
very very literal translation of what he
answered is this in Dark Souls 1 the
player is set as the undead because it
describes the inheriting or linking of
the fire but in Dark Souls 3 not only do
they the undead
become unsuccessful in becoming kindling
they also burn out after failing
unhindered is born of the leftover ashes
and what I think we take from this is
clarification into how we came to be and
kindled failed at kindling the fire but
we were still burned in some capacity
becoming ash and given we start near a
kiln filing shrine I'd say Aaron kindled
was undead tried to link the fire that
failed so our ashes exist in a graveyard
full of failed Undead and Kindle - in
contrast a Lord of cinder is someone who
was successful at linking the fire which
is why they were the first choice but
since they've refused to link the fire
again we're the next choice the ash of
failure rising again to fulfill the
cycle and it have us seek the Lords of
cinder and return them to their moulding
Thrones but we are talking
legends with the metal to make the fire
we're not fit to lick their boots don't
you think this is Hawk would a deserter
of ferren's undead legion probably
because the legion isn't in a very good
state right now the undead legion of
Ferren is a caravan of undead sworn by
wolf's blood to contain the abyss the
legion will bury a kingdom at the first
sign of exposure the point of Steel helm
was shirked as its sinister omen by the
masses probably because if you saw those
helmets then you knew your kingdom was
the one about to get buried so if you
played Dark Souls 1 then the
relationship between these abyss
Watchers and artorias the abyss walker'
should be very very clear Vittorio's was
a night of Guin with an unbreakable will
of Steel who took it upon himself and
his wolf to fight against the abyss
after it erupted in the ancient land of
oolacile and reincarnation of souls and
of purpose as well it's nothing new in
the souls universe so the abyss watchers
are a force that share
Artorius and his wolf's purpose split
between multiple bodies literally down
to the blood over the wolf that they all
share the wolf night helm reads a
vanquished knight left behind only
Wolf's blood and a legacy of duty
the undead legion of ferrand was formed
to bear his torch at the center of the
would we find the wolf itself best
described by the exile set which is worn
by two burly men who were guarding
herons cape iron mask of the watchdog's
of ferren's cape after the legions
Watchers became Lords of cinder the wolf
blood dried up and Ferren was consumed
by a festering wood within the wood and
emaciated old wolf commands watchdogs to
defend the sanctity of sleeping warriors
both the xl's were surely watchdogs
themselves for Ferren has always been a
land of hid inner UNS they're like for
part
of this item description and all of them
are interesting a curious part is the
description of the wolf as emaciated
which means abnormally thin or weak this
could suggest that the wolf is still
alive though maybe it doesn't really
matter if it is or not it's blood lives
on in the legion or at least it did
because it dried up when the legions
Watchers became Lords of cinder and it
seems quite obvious that the legion
disbanded when they did become loads of
cinder just like with artorias the wolf
lived on after his master was consumed
and just like in Dark Souls 1 it leads
to us joining a covenant the Covenant is
the watchdogs of Farren and the
watchdogs defend this area to ensure
that everyone who's resting here rests
serenely the age of the abyss Watchers
seems to have passed and all that left
is to respect the Warriors who have died
people invade to defend this place there
are hundreds of swords thrust into the
ground in a gesture of respect and the
sword grass you get is a reward for
defending the home of the spirit of
warriors past a symbol of acceptance and
gratitude so these two excels and
presumably other watchdogs like them
they found a sense of purpose in
defending the sanctity of the old
warriors and you can kind of understand
why there is this sense of respect
towards the Legion even after they're no
longer a force in the world
the undead legion is one of the only
mentions in the series of undead being
able to fight for something instead of
undead just being hated and locked up so
you can see how they would garner a lot
of respect but alas the abyss watching
of the undead legion appears to have
ended when they became lords of cinder
after the Watchers became lords of
cinder Ferren was consumed by a
festering wood these are the only words
that describe ferrand as a place not a
person so if you were wondering who the
hell is Ferren well this should answer
that Ferren is the festering wood itself
full of monstrous slugs horned grew go
to demons and darkwraiths
and another important tidbit in this
goldmine of a description is that it
tells us that
Herron was not always this way the main
evidence that this was once a better
place is the overwhelming links to all
the seal with its light sorceries it's
xanthus scholars and of course its race
of mushrooms it's implied that Ferran
swamp was Foresti all the seal or more
likely a parallel version of it which is
a concept that I'm sure we're familiar
with now and it doesn't look like it's
going anywhere anytime soon in this cave
one mushroom resembles Elizabeth the
talking mushroom of Dark Souls 1 and she
overlooks a golden scroll which talks of
oolacile where the sorceries
orchestrated light and were said to
shine in golden hues she also overlooks
the antiquated dress which was worn by
dusk princess of oolacile whose crown is
found by one of the three white birch
trees of Dark Soul three little Dusk's
first sorceress staff eventually became
a seedling and then three white birch
saplings the young branch is said to
still contain echos of little Basques
capriciousness the description of dusk
as capricious was new to me and it's
also a mirrored in the game's
description for chameleons witch's spell
found later in the game and if the spell
that does the same thing has the
branches chameleon reads far from
formally developed this magic was
instead born from the mischief of a
young girl who sought relief from the
solitude of the woods at dusk so perhaps
this mischievous nature this is sneaking
away was how dusk was snatched up by
Manas all that time ago regardless is
just really nice to have a bit more
personality put into dusk the white
birches of dusk are also guarded by this
giant wielding Goths great Bo and Gough
himself would have known who dusk was
since he existed at all the seal at that
time so there's another reason why the
giant protects these birch trees from
harm and finally the lost arts of
oolacile in this place are championed by
yellow finger hazel who's a xanthus
scholar she wields the hazel pick firing
great fair endure
and Ferran Hale which are described as
her own sorceries that went on to be
refined by a crystal sage
what's the undead Legion doing with a
cold such as this like I heard one of
the crystal sages have sided with
Ference abyss watchers I suppose it must
be true the crystal sages desire
knowledge which is a legacy of master
Logan and it's also described in the
crystal rapier as their devotion to a
lifetime of research the rapier also
improves your item discovery crystal
hail a adaptation of Ferran Hale says
that the sages made a pact to ally with
the undead legion and train their
sorcerers though given that crystal Hale
is an adaptation of Ferran Hale it's
possible they learn from each other
parind art and Ferran Hale are said to
have originally been entrusted to the
legions acolytes curiously the rotten
guru dagger said that the guru are
descendants of the acolytes
of Ferran keep suggesting that these
primitive demon like goat creatures
surely were not always this way or at
least they had time to devolve to this
state they still seemed allied with
Philly Jian even now and they face away
from the Great Cape where the abyss
watchers resided Spears in hand ready
even to face against two approaching
darkwraiths who likely threaten the
abyss watchers in the same way that they
threatened Artorius all that time ago in
all the seal so Paran keep has the
sorceries it has the characters and it
has the same corrupted inhabitants that
all the seal of Dark Souls one it even
hide the gear of Faris who is the
legendary Archer who defended the
resting place of stiff so long ago so
the inevitable question is what is the
law reason for the recycling of the same
concepts and in the last episode we
heard conics say that the lands of the
lords converge upon the Freak the home
of pyromancies drift compare
to be close as well and Emma told us
that the Lord's homes are churning and
the lothric banner states that the high
wall just appeared look at this bridge
as well it also looks like it used to
line up with BOTS
Chamber only for the entire city of La
Frick to apparently be pulled up towards
the heavens upon a mountain of stone so
it's not just time
that's convoluted space clearly is as
well
the fabric of the world is pretty damn
broken in Dark Souls 3 and we'll see
that in later episodes even more before
lothric was heaved upwards on its
mountain of stone the stray demon above
the old wolf of Ferren was its
gatekeeper this class of demons has
always been used as powerful gatekeepers
and take the ones in the asylum for
instance this one in particular has lost
its flame for the chaos flame is dying
its body is brittle and it spews
boulders instead of flame further on is
a Drake which looks like he is crashed
into the bridge and from the items you
pick up it's pretty clear that there
were Knights here who brought him down
and that that's the story they're trying
to tell lightning spears are effective
against Dragon kin and one of them is
found on a corpse here the dragon crest
shield greatly reduces fire damage and
it's found nearby as well from on high
you can easily track down the three
flames that you need to open the door to
the abyss Watchers gaining admission to
the Legion is a matter of some ceremony
inside there keep snuffing out the
flames of three orders opens the door to
the wolf blood even a curse it undead
believe they're special it seems I pity
the sorry selves from outside you hear
the clash of swords within two of the
abyss watchers are fighting each other
but why you have to ask my first thought
was that it could simply be for practice
since when they die they rise from the
dead anyway right but that would imply
that they're sane and what sane boss
fights itself when the uncontested lis
attacking anything they see similar to
the way artorias did you know except now
they're stuck in a room fighting
themselves endlessly but yeah there's
nothing concrete here for sure your
theories are just as good as mine the
dagger is utilized as a wedge in the
left hand while the great sword is held
in the right a technique synonymous with
the undead legion confounds foes in the
manner of wolves hunting prey wolves
hunt as a pack and they aim to preserve
themselves they single out their prey
and they prod for weaknesses in their
prey and it's called to see that the
abyss Watchers weaponry makes reference
to this the old wolf curved sword which
is one of my favorite weapons it tells
you how you slice downwards and then you
jump away from harm just before it can
hit you and the Ferren great sword has
that little nip with the short blade
before using the stun to hit them with
the full force of the blade so the sword
and the dagger are symbolic of the way I
imagined the knight and the wolf would
have fought but merged into one every
Lord of cinder has a second phase where
they become imbued with flame and in the
abyss Watchers case the blood of the
wolf coalesce into one form their shared
wolf's blood is what served as their
mandate as Lords allowing them to link
the fire but now that they're
resurrected if the Lords will not return
to the thrones themselves then let them
return as cinders I failed
you for helping them find their final
resting place
I pity the sorry selves is that really
Lordships
last reward so pork wood was once part
of the Legion as well
but he was one of the only ones with a
shield the unique swordsmanship of the
Watchers would not allow such a shield
and Hawk woods very possession of it was
telltale of his defeat in the next
episode we venture into the Cathedral of
the deep and hopefully we'll learn a
little bit more about the abyss down
there and to keep you guys posted the
next videos are most likely going to be
the soul song and then a description of
all the bosses in the game and if you're
still listening you're in the minority
because most people click off by now but
thank you for watching
you